COMMITTEE TO ORDER --
MADAM SECRETARY IF YOU WILL
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SENATORS
GROWTH.
GROWTH HERE MONNING HERE MONNING
HERE ROUGH.
ROUGH HERE WILK ATKINS HERE
ATKINS HERE WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU --
I WILL I WILL DO THIS.
IN ORDER I'M HAPPY TO TAKE A THE
MOTION FROM ANY OF THE MEMBERS
FOR A CONSENT AGENDA IF YOU
WOULD LIKE AND THEN WE'LL GO
FROM THERE IF SOMEONE WANTS US
[inaudible]
TO OKAY.
MR OZ SENATOR ROTH WOULD YOU ON
LET ME KNOW WHAT ITEMS YOU WOULD
MOVE.
I TO PUT ON THAT.
CONSENT FOR CONSENT.
OKAY SO ITEMS.
ONE AM BE ITEM TO ITEM.
THREE THAT WOULD BE ITEM FOUR
AND FIVE ITEM NUMBER SIX AND
THEN THE FLOOR KNOWLEDGE MONTHS
WOULD BE ITEM SEVEN THROUGH.
TEN ANY LET ME GIVE A SECOND FOR
PEOPLE TO CHECK THIS OUT AND SEE
IF THEY'RE IN CONCURRENCE.
OKAY THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL SENATORS GROWTH.
GROVE I MONNING MONNING AYE ROTH.
ROTH AYE WILK ATKINS AYE ATKINS
I SHOULD BE.
ARE WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN A CAN
WE JUST LET ME MAKE SURE I'M
CLEAR WITH MY COUNSEL WE CAN
LEAVE EXECUTIVE SESSION.
BECAUSE WE ARE GOING INTO
EXECUTIVE SESSION I WANNA MAKE
SURE WE'RE DOING THIS
APPROPRIATELY [inaudible]
HI OKAY.
I I THINK I I THINK WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND CLOSE THE ROLE.
OKAY THANK YOU.
WITH THAT ARE WE WILL MOVE INTO
EXECUTIVE SESSION